mobile teams dispatched in Daegu to
disinfect the site of the country's
worst mass outbreak of the corona virus
the Shin songi Church of Jesus were a 61
year old woman attended services while
infected health authorities described it
as a super spreading event the mayor has
advised people to stay indoors raising
fears that the city of 2.5 million is
the next global hotspot for the virus
with more confirmed cases here in Daegu
than in Seoul I'm worried that Daegu
will become the second Wuhan the charge
should have been more careful the church
has a reputation as a cult in South
Korea and issued this apology we are
deeply sorry that one of our members who
thought of her condition as a cold
because she had not traveled abroad led
to many in her church being infected and
caused concern to the local community
this is dagoes temporary treatment
center for people showing symptoms more
than 80 church members have confirmed
infections and there could be many more
so far we have checked with 4475 church
members and among them 544 answered that
they had symptoms so they are undergoing
the virus tests we have obtained a list
of remaining church members and are
taking measures Seoul is also on edge
over the virus health workers retrace
the path of a coronavirus patient who
reportedly used the train authorities
have also banned rallies to fight the
outbreak some families aren't taking any
chances
missing big life events like this
Father's own university graduation and
watching it online
with the explosion of infections hitting
the country many South Koreans worry the
worst is yet to come
meanwhile on the other side of the world
there have been violent clashes in
Ukraine over fears that evacuees
arriving in the country from China were
infected with the coronavirus fears over
the spread of the coronavirus trigger an
eruption of violence thousands of
kilometers from China efforts to
quarantine more than 70 people evacuated
from Wuhan plunged this Ukrainian town
into chaos
hundreds of protesters clashed with riot
police into the night aren't you afraid
of being infected it has spread all over
the world even to Egypt but those
countries can't be compared with ours
why didn't they prepare and organize the
somewhere else not in our village aren't
adjusted to isolate them here we don't
want to become an isolation zone an
exclusion zone we are going to live here
and we don't want this to become a new
Wuhan violence erupted outside the
facility where the evacuees are now
under quarantine
[Music]
[Applause]
locals tried to block the road they're
lighting fires and pelting the arriving
buses with stones
authorities say the 45 Ukrainians and 27
foreign nationals on board had been
screened twice for the virus before
being allowed to fly Paul evacuated
people who are at the hospital are
healthy there are no reasons to say that
there are ill the king who chose tiny
logistical measures are under way to
accommodate people comfortably the Prime
Minister has tried to assure locals they
have nothing to worry about the Health
Minister has agreed to stay with these
people in this hospital to demonstrate
that there is no threat to Ukraine Ian's
several offices and civilians were
injured in the violence dozens of
protesters were arrested